we all love ourselves more than other
people
but care more about their opinion than
our own
what we do now Echoes In
eternity
the sayings of Marcus Aurelius are able
to reveal the inexhaustible energy in
everyone and teach how
with the help of simple thoughts
you can rule over yourself and lead your
life
do Every Act of your life as though it
were the very last Act of your life
a person's worth is measured by the
worth of what he values
Soul becomes died with the color of its
thoughts
the thing you think about determine the
quality of your mind
receive without conceit
release without struggle
you have power over your mind
not outside events
realize this and you will find strength
we live only now
everything else is either passed or is
unknown
a man must stand Direct
not be kept erect by others
people are not disturbed by things but
by the views they take of them
dig Within
within is the Wellspring of good
and it is always ready to Bubble Up if
you just dig
confine yourself to the present
everything a horse a Vine is created for
some Duty
for what task then
where you yourself created
choose not to be harmed
and you won't feel harmed
don't feel harmed
you haven't been
when you arise in the morning
think of what a privilege it is to be
alive to think to enjoy
to love
no man is Happy who does not think so
for himself
death Smiles at us all
all we can do is smile back
the happiness of your life depends upon
the quality of your thoughts
what we cannot bear removes us from life
what remains can be born
everything we hear is an opinion not a
fact
everything we see is a perspective not
the truth
humans have come into being for the sake
of each other
so either teach them or learn to Bear
them
be like the cliff against which the
waves continually break
but it stands firm and tames the fury of
the water around it
waste no more time arguing about what a
good man should be
B1
your days are numbered use them to throw
open the windows of your soul to the Sun
if you do not the sun will soon set
and you with it
the best revenge is to be unlike him who
performed the injury
the longer a man is lonely the more he
can draw on the influence of loneliness
on him
it is important for every person to be
able to remain alone and put up with
himself in order to find inner peace
do what you will
even if you tear yourself apart most
people will continue doing the same
things
it is not death that a man should fear
but he should fear never beginning to
live
our life is what our thoughts make it
whenever you are about to find fault
with someone
ask yourself the following question
What fault of mine most nearly resembles
the one I am about to criticize
if it is not right do not do it
if it is not true do not say it
very little is needed to make a happy
life
it is all within yourself in your way of
thinking
reject your sense of injury and the
injury itself disappears
[Music]
the first rule is to keep an untroubled
spirit
the second is to look things in the face
and know them for what they are
except whatever comes to you woven in
the pattern of your destiny
for what could more aptly fit your needs
how much more Grievous are the
consequences of anger
than the causes of it
do not act as if you were going to live
Ten Thousand Years
death hangs over you
while you live while it is in your power
be good
here is a rule to remember in the future
when anything tempts you to feel bitter
not this is Misfortune but to bear this
worthily is good fortune
how much time he gains who does not look
to see what his neighbor says or does or
thinks
but only what he does himself
to make it just and holy
the impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
it is in your power to withdraw yourself
whenever you desire
perfect Tranquility within consists in
the good ordering of the Mind
the realm of your own
do not indulge in dreams of having what
you have not
but reckon up the chief of the blessings
you do possess
and then thankfully remember how you
would crave for them if they were not
yours
If any man despises you
that is his problem
your only concern should be in doing or
saying anything
deserving of contempt
whoever does wrong wrongs himself
whoever does injustice
does it to himself
making himself evil
that which is really beautiful has no
need of anything
not more than law not more than truth
not more than benevolence or modesty
the memory of everything is very soon
overwhelmed in time
nowhere can man find a quieter or more
untroubled retreat
than in his own soul
because the thing seems difficult for
you do not think it impossible for
anyone to accomplish
no man can escape his destiny
the next inquiry being how he may best
live the time that he has to live
regain your senses call yourself back
and once again wake up
now that you realize that only dreams
are troubling you
view this reality as you view your
dreams
take full account of what excellencies
you possess
and in gratitude remember how you would
hanker after them if you had them not
observe always that everything is the
result of change
and get used to thinking that there is
nothing nature loves so well
as to change existing forms and make new
ones like them
how ridiculous and unrealistic is the
man who was astonished at anything that
happens in life
[Music]
we have collected these quotes from
Marcus Aurelius that show us all the
thoughts Inside the Mind of a stoic
philosopher by listening to these quotes
you can develop clear judgment simple
thoughts and intercom
thanks for watching